qui a dit que les courses de tracteurs à
pédales n'était réservé qu'aux enfants
ce week end à civray de touraine tous
les âges s'en sont donné à coeur joie
pour la première édition des games bonne
ambiance petite chute tout ça pour la
bonne cause
la descente de rue en tracteur à pédales
c'est un retour en enfance pour les
concurrents les plus âgés c'est aussi le
souvenir de quelques égratignures
chez moi j'avais aussi une des 100 donc
j'en faisais aussi avec mon tracteur
puis un jour le portail était fermé j'ai
fini les genoux dans le prêt dans le
portail et je me concentre donc c'était
pas mal un peu mal pour cette course à
civray de touraine il fallait donc
porter casques genouillères et coudières
pour que les cascades reste dans la
bonne humeur
là j'ai voulu attraper le drapeau j'ai
perdu le contrôle j'ai pas freiné jefri
les bottes de paille ce super mario kart
car il n'y a pas que la vitesse il y à
aussi la dextérité la conduite de
l'engin pour gagner des points il faut
attraper des drapeaux comme on attrape
le pompon aux
questions techniques de vitesse ce sont
les jeunes pilotes qui maîtrise le mieux
en fait faut
pousser pousser pousser
quant aux bénéfices récoltés grâce à la
trentaine de pilotes ils iront à
l'association hypophosphatasie europe
pour lutter contre une maladie qui
touche une enfant de la commune c'est un
moyen de la soutenir de se tenir à les
parents et de serre connaître ces
maladies ou ceux qui ont voulu tricher
en introduisant un moteur dans le
véhicule ont été vite repéré est
disqualifié